before Britney Spears was an  international superstar  she was this girl yep that's Britt Britt  back in 1998 when she was just 16 years  old an aspiring pop star hanging out on  the set of her very first music video  for baby one more time  the singer shared this cute throwback to  Instagram Tuesday posing with director  Nigel dick she captioned the photo quote  most precious day of my life but Britt  wasn't the only one feeling nostalgic  Nigel was too he reminisced on Facebook  quotes at the time there were people who  questioned why I would think of making  this video for an unknown 16 year old I  told them the song was going to be  massive and that you had something  special so glad you showed up I was  right I'm really blessed